we have been warned this weekend is
going to be extremely hot and although
it may get uncomfortable to try and wear
a mask in the heat experts say don't
stop wearing them Joe Moller spoke to a
medical expert and he brings us more
from the southwest part of the valley
tonight as the temperature goes up over
the next few days one medical expert
says wearing a cloth mask might be the
best idea the paper masks that are
typically one-time-use won't last as
long when they get what especially from
sweat with the heat and 95 masks are not
recommended because they are harder to
breathe in and experts say they should
be kept for medical professionals the
heats may make mask uncomfortable but it
is still recommended comfortable there's
absolutely no risk for wearing a mask I
even in the heat the Dean of the UNLV
School of Medicine mark Khan says the
heat does not reduce the potential
exposure to the virus he says if you are
in public and around people to wear a
mask
he also says if you are uncomfortable
wearing a mask in the middle of the heat
during the day maybe head outdoors when
it's cooler at night or in the morning
reporting in the Southwest Valley Joe
Moller
8 News now